ja liebe leute das kranken unter unseren
videos auf dem kanal überall es geht
weiter und ich sage euch ich kann es
verstehen und ich sage euch ich habe ein
echtes kleines problem der liebe krank
meldet sich nicht ich kann ihn anrufen
so oft ich will mailbox geht dann zu
hause geht er nicht ran und ich will
euch zeigen hier ist mein iphone habe
ich gestern erst erfolgreich geschrottet
funktioniert aber noch ich wähle seine
nummer und stellt direkt mal auf
lautsprecher und dann hört ihr folgendes
ihr habt gehört
ich hab's ans mikrofon gehalten ja das
höre ich immer wieder ich habe ihn schon
oft auf die mailbox gesprochen er hat
noch nicht zurückrufen aber ich bin fest
davon überzeugt weil er hat es
versprochen hat dass frage video gedreht
er wird euch nicht verarschen er kommt
so kriegst du nur ich kann nicht krank
ich kann nicht sagen wann er wird auf
jeden fall kommen ich bin ganz sicher
habt geduld stay tuned wie ich immer so
schön sagen und dann wenn er etwas
entspannt dann kommt er plötzlich also
bleibt dran und bleibt uns gewogen und
es wird schon nichts schief gehen er
wird kommen ich bin ganz sicher